good morning Hank it's Tuesday so you
recently made a video outside and I was
like we have outside in Indiana so yeah
Here I am one of my favorite words in
English is mortification it's also one
of my least favorite things to
experience and last week I was well and
truly mortified when I used the word
hectacre like 135 times in my video
about agriculture in Ethiopia I said
heck taker like one who takes HEC when
in fact I meant hectare meeting 100
Aires with air being a unit of measure
that means 100 square meters now
admittedly units measuring land area not
among my fields of expertise but still I
was trying to share with people what
I've learned about how to make more food
available to hungry people but obviously
I knew absolutely nothing because
hectacre
heck I've only experienced real
mortification a couple times in my adult
life like my first book signing after
Looking for Alaska was published was
only attended by two people that I was
obviously concerning but it wasn't
really mortifying until I was halfway
through my reading and I read a sentence
from the book that went the only thing
worse than having a party that no one
attends is having a party attended by
two vastly deeply uninteresting people
thereby managing to insult the only two
people nice enough to come to my signing
then a few years later I was giving a
talk to several hundred high school
students none of whom had any idea who I
was and I talked for about 45 minutes
everyone was laughing a lot they seemed
to be having a great time and finally I
was like are there any questions at
which point several dozen people raised
their hands which is very unusual and I
was like yeah yes do you have a question
and they're like yeah mr. green are you
aware that your fly is open now hike to
be clear it wasn't that my zipper was
down my fly was open like you could see
my underwear and then I was like no I
wasn't aware that my fly was down it
turned around a zipped up my fly I
turned back around I was like are there
any other questions silence wait have I
told that story to vlogbrothers video
before now I feel a little bit of
mortification creeping in again lauric I
don't even know what's been in my own
videos but anyway back to hectacre so
Cera was trying to comfort me and she
was like you know nerdfighters don't
care that much about this stuff they're
so forgiving and nice it'll be fine and
she was also like no offense but it's
not like that many people outside of
nerdfighteria are gonna see your video
because you know it's about agricultural
yields in the developing world it's not
going to catch fire on tumblr and then
of course within a day Bill Gates the
head of the World Food Program and the
Foreign Minister of Ethiopia had all
seen the video not
we're all very nice about it but you
know that secretly they were like
hectacre
so it's one thing to look like a
grapefruit in front of nerdfighteria
Hank they've come to expect it but Bill
Gates mortifying now a mortification is
something that you're doing entirely to
yourself as it wasn't this instance
there can be something useful about it
maybe like I want to seem like the kind
of person who knows a lot about
agriculture or the kind of person who
can get through a two-person book
signing without alienating the audience
and mortification can be your ideas
about yourself being challenged by the
reality of yourself and that's not such
a bad thing but when other people try to
mortify you when they say cruel things
about you to make you feel embarrassed
of yourself or when they read your diary
or share pictures that you wish to
remain private that's very different I
don't think anything is gained there and
a lot is lost heck I don't think any of
us can navigate the world always having
to be our public selves even when in
private because I think we'd go mad now
God knows I'll never say hectacre in a
vlogbrothers video again but if I can't
say it at home I'm seriously kind of
doomed because then I'd lose touch with
my real and actual self which for all of
us is necessarily different from the
selves we project in public we all act
differently in private than we do in
school or at our jobs or on tumblr mag I
can't speak for everyone but I for one
wouldn't want to have to be on tumblr
all the time well no no because my kids
don't have tumblers yet anyway Hank if
you've learned one thing from being my
brother I hope it is this hectare rhymes
with nectar almost rhymes with lecture
not really those by the way are called
slant rhymes
he said confidently feeling a whisper of
doubt I'll see on Friday